j'ai oublié un truc à occire et que
c'est la journée des dj oui donc vous
devez à chaque fois regarder la caméra
en faisant un cri de ninja parce qu'ils
ont ramené des planchers tout vous ça va
être une table donc moi sera castaldi
pour geof est inquiet de ninja salut
[Applaudissements]
on sait qu'on reconnaît les ninjas parce
qu ils se faufilent on les voit pas
ouais donc écrit pas parce que sinon les
remarques un petit peu de cas fait déjà
ouais mais là c'est un ninja qui a envie
qu'on sache qu'il est lassé genre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
roddick usa il faut dire n'importe quoi
aujourd'hui chez jean michel mr et la
merci des âmes aujourd'hui très bien
kawaii nous
[Rires]
même pas sacré bon je sais pas ça serait
un peu japonais s'émousser au kaki kaki
jean-luc vous avez toujours me demandais
arbres
[Musique]
j'vous dis quand même que si en france
on réussit à faire là dessus la sûreté
du ninja c'est qu'on est bien c'est que
c'était utile
jean-luc ou comment vous ne trouvez vous
êtes sur un 13e mois ci motif c'est
dommage ce qui a changé sa plus du tout
vous dire la même chose en plus monsieur
[Applaudissements]
sur moi mais même sur un cri des rôles
ou même sur un cri on voit qu'il n'est
pas
[Applaudissements]
je connais mes frères que vous savez
faire
derrière c'est la cousine de belém
rochon gilles verdez et l'amertume
wedia
[Applaudissements]
sans déconner moi ça veut dire quoi
parce que eux laurence voulait dire
quelque chose alors pour elle vous
n'avez pas faire une ligne j'ai fait
plutôt jeanine isabelle bacon ça il va
t'en isabelle moret niveau à sathonay
attendait ça va oui mais voilà déjà
essayé de me le mettre en bouche mais
bureautique de dijon c'est pas mal ça me
plaît de la taille je vous jure j'ai de
la peine pour la paire ces fameux
bouquin madame brossard et capucine à la
merci
[Applaudissements]
alors ma chérie pas possible jean luc
lennon mais ninja c'est pas ça écrit pas
il disparaît
[Applaudissements]
jean lui convenait vous voulez pas voir
mon camarade c'est ça
[Musique]